[Musique]
la légende dit que tous les bateaux qui
s'en sont rapprochés on finit par tomber
du bord de la terre on les a jamais
retrouvé lé marins qui ont sont revenus
parle de gigantesque et magnifique
cascade et de dragons qui garde l'entrée
d'un monde caché pas seulement le nid
awad
mais une terre d'où sont originaires
tous les dragons
c'est vrai les ferries nocturnes ainsi
pour et surtout les furie nocturne
il faut trop parler fieri ne t'inquiète
pas un jour je trouverai le monde caché
et je condamnerai l'accès pour qu'enfin
les humains et les dragons cesse de se
battre
je reconnais le style de ce travail
rimmel le grave faut bien admettre que
par chez moi tout le monde le connaît ce
chasseur si le plus malin enfin après
moi bien c'est ben il doit pas être si
malin il a laissé un piège sans
surveillance n'ont rien est accidentelle
quand on parle de ce vieux crime elle il
ne vit que pour la chasse entrer dans la
tête de sa proie et pouvoir contrôler
ses moindres faits et gestes
tout ça n'est qu'un jeu produit sauf que
cette fois il va trouver du monde en
taxi way on a déjà affronté des types
comme les ne sous-estiment pas gay mais
le grave parce qu'il va revenir
tu peux me croire alors on l'attend de
pied ferme
qu'est ce que tu a repéré un moment
[Applaudissements]
attends qu
[Musique]
regardez djibo la salue on chante et on
va pouvoir faire
[Musique]
mais génial pains seulement
il croit qu'elle doit tout diriger seul
lorsque son père lui maple choix il ne
se rend pas compte à quel point vous
êtes fort tous les deux tu crois en lui
comme chef de tribu
oui bien sûr je voudrais qu'il y croit
aussi mais harold et certains qui n'est
rien sans son dragon head le simplement
ouvrir les yeux dans ce cas
quand j'étais petit le monde grouillait
de dragon rares sont ceux qui savent où
ils sont allés notre histoire a changé
le monde à jamais on a réussi un monde
idéal où vivent en harmonie dragon
speaking bonbons d'idéal mon lit des
halles à moi à moi j'ai compris jj année
au moment où tu vas
au mieux il est donc pas lui c'est un
dragon semaine or désolé et vient de se
volatiliser
un monde caché de dragon
présenté comme on a une petite copine
j'ai chassé tous les furie nocturne
excepté le tiers livre le mois jamais je
ne livrerai dans ce cas je détruirai
tout ce que tu tiens
on est plus en sécurité ici on doit tous
se cacher disparaître
nous devons nous battre pour leur
liberté allez bon vent
santon dragon tu n'es rien
montrent leur ce que tu as dans le
ventre
[Musique]
sauf le
toi et moi mon grand pour toujours
hu
[Musique]